the cabinet office has sought leave to
bring a judicial review so it is as we
have been speculating for a day or two
uh we do so with regret and with an
assurance we will continue to cooperate
fully with the inquiry before during and
after the jurisdictional issuing
question is determined by the courts
specifically whether the inquiry has the
power to compel production of documents
and messages which are unambiguously
irrelevant a phrase we've heard the last
couple of days
um unambiguously relevant to the
inquiries work including personal
Communications and matters unconnected
to the government's handling of covid we
consider this there to be important
issues of principle at stake here
affecting both the rights of individuals
and the proper conduct of government the
request for unambiguously irrelevant
material goes beyond the powers of the
inquiry individuals Junior officials
current and former ministers and
departments should not be required to
provide material that is irrelevant to
the inquiry's work it represents an
unwarranted intrusion into other aspects
of the work of government it also
represents an intrusion into their
legitimate expectations of privacy and
protection of their personal information
so there we have confirmation in the
last few seconds from the cabinet office
they are sticking by their hard line
that the demands being made by baroness
Hallett constitute an intrusion into the
private lives of what they describe as
individuals Junior officials currents
and former ministers they should not be
required to provide material that is
irrelevant to the inquiries work so the
battle is heading to the courts it is
from Rishi sunak a heading for a
showdown and not a climb down